The Joe Rogan Experience what year did
you start out first of all
July 79 oh wow
what was the scene like well it was the
comedy connection
the little one downstairs
it was uh on Warrington Street it was
street level
that was the first one
before next before next so it was the
same comedy store or excuse me the same
um one that was uh the Charles Playhouse
right yeah yeah you got straight in yeah
and it was right in there it's an
amazing room yeah little like 150 people
probably I don't even think that many
maybe 100 maybe 90
that was the first ceiling yeah yeah low
that's where I
I went to see an open mic there and then
I thought
I what I was doing is I was you know
into comedy from watching The Tonight
Show that's when I really got like oh
these comedians you know Carol and
Robert Klein
all these guys I had to watch this
Tonight Show because my brother was
older than me and we had to watch what
he wanted
so I you know I started watching then I
started to like it
and then I I heard that there was a club
in town and I thought
I ground you know I was 16 when I really
was into it but then when I was about 23
I heard of the club and I thought well
maybe I gotta go try it out I mean I
wouldn't have to move to Los Angeles or
New York and I didn't I my character
then I couldn't have 23 I'm not going to
move to Los Angeles it was like a
that was too much for me
so I went to the comedy connection and I
watched a show and then I learned that
there was a
the open mic nights was every Wednesday
so then I thought I'm gonna go back in
two weeks
do you remember your first set
I don't remember I remember the first
joke was but I don't remember the rest
of it was I said I uh went into a
a bookstore and I thought it started
talking to this very French looking girl
she was a bilingual illiterate she
couldn't read in two different languages
and then it
and that's how you started yeah I had
about three minutes
so did you always ride in that style
like the sort of non-sequitur absurdist
you know see I didn't even write
anything until I went to the open my
watched the show and when I knew I was
going back in two weeks during that two
weeks I wrote things but I had never
written comedy at all right but when you
first started writing comedy it was
always that style it was about 70
percent like that it was more like
normalish
I don't know why it came out like that I
mean
I I you know I was influenced by Carl
and
talking about everyday Little Things
and that's what I actually oh I'm gonna
do that
and then the structure of a joke was
from listening to Woody Allen's stand-up
albums hmm but that I had no that's just
how it came out
with those two influences plus my own
mind your writing process must be you
you have a very difficult style to write
for I would imagine
because your style is it's uh it's
non-sequiturs and they're very like a
lot of it's very absurd like is it is it
hard to like when you write you sit in
front of a computer do you just come up
with ideas as you're walking around like
what's your process
in the beginning I would sit down and
look at the paper like look for a word
to Jazz my mind or look for something
and I would try to find jokes on purpose
in the first six months
and then after that like I had this
thing once I was looking through the
paper and it was an advertisement for
electrolysis
and I thought what an interesting word
just the sound of the word what it means
both things it won't what the what the
hell right so I made a note of that and
then
I don't know my mind you know because
your subconscious is like a factory it's
working when you don't even know that it
is minding your own business you're in
line doing something that's this just in
yeah
and what in my mind did with that was I
came up I had this thing about them
living in an apartment building where
they allowed pets and I had a pony I had
a Shetland pony named Nikki and he he
was once involved in a bizarre
electrolysis accident all the hair was
removed except for the tail now I rent
him out to Hari Krishna family picnics
and that whole thing came because I saw
the word electrolysis
so I would try to find things on purpose
but then after a while I didn't my mind
was
I would just notice things because I
think Comedy All art is based on
noticing what's around you and I would
my my mind like I drew a lot I know that
you used to draw too and you know I'm
sure I realistically in high school and
stuff and like if you were going to draw
this cup and this this you the two
shapes and then you notice if you're
trying to draw it real you this shape
this shape and then there's the shape
that's in between that's also a shape
which helps you get it accurate and but
so you know you don't really notice that
shape unless you were trying to jar it
so I think that that exercise my mind of
noticing then later on doing the comedy
I was already noticing but I think was
noticing just some people are very aware
of what's around and you know like in
the tower in the at the airport where
the radar goes like this like it goes
like this like and then there's the
little beeps of the planes like those
are the planes so I think my mind got
like
scanning like that subconscious like I
I'm not going on I don't walk down the
street thinking I need another joke I'm
gonna go walk down that street I'm just
going around my day just doing it but
the sub the thing is going right
it'll see a word it's like
oh oh maybe that oh okay and then oh and
then like
write it down I think it'll show the
wording comes pretty fast like very like
in a minute it's like because in my mind
it can only be one way it can be written
and then I just would write it down and
then and then go on with what I was
doing but the the noticing never stops
don't you think what you do is you're
reacting right
you're talking about the world but you
have to
really see the world yeah you have to
really see the world top quality you
can't get better than those guys you
can't get better than those guys I
really laugh out loud
I think ever I think ever of all my
years of Comedy I mean it's hard now
because you you go back and watch it now
it's like you got to realize it's a
totally different time in the world it's
it's not it's not um it doesn't
it's not our culture it's a different
culture it's a culture of 1980s things
were more risque they're more like when
you said things that were more shocking
and a lot of that stuff's already been
said so many times now that if you go
back and listen to it it's like some of
it doesn't really hold up the same way
but for the time in those days those
guys were the cream of the crop
and if you had to follow them in Boston
like good [__] luck because I don't
think anybody ever killed heart I didn't
I didn't those guys I didn't want to go
on after them I did because I was proud
of the lineup but I knew that the the
sound from the audience of the laughs I
knew they were gonna it was gonna be
more than me but I just accepted it
because it was like wave you know in a
big wave
yeah all of those guys yeah
Gavin Sweeney
Donovan did you feel any pressure to
sort of uh ever to change or act in the
beginning before you made it whether it
was it like were you just committed to
that kind of style
it was well committed his means a
decision there was no decision it was
like like I told you that's how I wrote
it and it came out like that it messed
with how I speak this is how I speak and
for some reason
accidentally the abstract jokes went
good with my voice but the audience they
weren't thrown off from it people ask me
well they you know it was different with
the audience take a while to come around
and they didn't because right from the
first three minutes they laughed at some
of it and they didn't laugh at other
things so then I knew right then it
wasn't how I was saying it or my voice
or anything they would they don't care
about anything I don't give a [__] as
long as it's funny yeah so they thought
some of it was funny and some of it
wasn't and Mike McDonald helped me a lot
because he saw me the first time and I
was naively disappointed because I
didn't laugh at everything which is
insane but I was out being naive and he
said look
take that material he never did it
before take that set and take out the
stuff that didn't work and put all this
stuff in that works I mean it should try
out and when I left from him telling me
that I thought it was a success because
they laughed at some of it here I am
wanting to I was 16 wanting to try it
and then I they left it a minute and a
half I oh my God they left it so then he
made me lead when I left I was like oh
my God oh my God I gotta keep changing
and changing and changing but I didn't
think of changing my style or anything
because like I was saying with
fingerprint before it was just just how
it just what it was it didn't even enter
my mind to change it yeah some of it
works some of it didn't change it try
more try more try more
and I'm glad there wasn't any Show
Business there because someone might
have said you can't be mumbling over on
the side
get a sport jacket and talk loud you
know what I mean there was no one
watching yeah from that angling right
and all of those guys we were just
talking about none of them are like the
next guy right no I was like not it was
like a factory that only made one car
and then they made a different car yeah
you know it was like a Mustang then this
there was no assembly line yeah every
one of those guys is completely unique
everyone yeah
it's um that one of the interesting
things about the documentary when
stand-up stood out was that you were
kind of the first guy that got
discovered in Boston
and then you took off and then it became
a different thing because then people
realized that that was possible and so
then there was a in the documentary at
least there was this attitude where a
lot of guys had like hey what about me
like where's my where's my thing how
come it's not happening for me you know
I'm a headliner I'm gonna this some of
that like why why isn't this and it
became where a lot of guys were trying
to make it now
do you remember that time I knew later
when uh when I heard about it after I
had gone but I mean but we all wanted to
go on the TV like I mean that everyone
wasn't doing it just to be doing it in
Boston I wanted to someday go on TV I
had no idea how I would get there and
then I got a lucky break because
beautiful Sally came to Boston and he
saw me in the club because it was an
article about the Ding Ho and freelance
writer wrote about it and went into the
LA Times this weird Comedy Club Chinese
restaurant and then he read it and then
he went back East looking at colleges
for his kids were getting out of high
school they did a summer trip
to Boston and New York to look at
schools and you remember the article and
he called up the club I'm going to go in
and you know and then he saw me and then
I went went on there so I got a very uh
lucky
break but I know you're talking about
like I mean I was just saying insanely
lucky
and then but that uh friends movie I
mean he never even made a movie before
right he never made a movie I know and
that was a very interesting thing
because say we were all rowers like a
rogue guy is not gonna make a movie he's
not but a comedian a creative guy he's
gonna make a movie about the time you
don't have a movie of your time in high
school or your best time in college we
have a document by one of our own guys
of the time yeah and it's still all of
us one of our favorite times in our
whole lives so it's a precious gift that
Fran made the movie to see to see this
thing